Chris Mannix joins us on loan from Yahoo
Sports their senior NBA writer and of
course he is coming in to pay up a bet
recap the bet there Mannix for the
audience I believe it started back in
November when I wrote the column after
the Celtics knocked off Golden State it
was like a fifth of the way through the
season and I said it's a wrap in the
Eastern Conference Celtics are gonna win
and you caught on to that and we made a
little from friendly wage now things
change during the season right the Cavs
made a bunch of trades the Celtics they
lost Kyrie Irving but I think we both
kind of decided to allow the bet to
stand in the Conference Finals once
those two teams got there well I respect
that with you but you can't call it over
in November therefore I had to I had to
call you on that so ok injuries and
Kyrie didn't play and LeBron you know
reinvented his lineup but that's why you
don't call it in November you're right
but all things being equal with that
Boston team I didn't even care what the
Cavs did I thought the Cavs could have
made whatever move they wanted to that
Boston team was gonna beat them but you
lose you know your all-star point guard
if Kyrie didn't get hurt Boston wins
that but do they win the final I mean
they're just look they play I mean they
play Golden State exceptionally well
it's not just you know this season it's
last season which tells me it's as much
about the style of play and the way they
defend the only way to beat Golden State
moving forward is if you have kind of a
switch happy defense if you get a bunch
of versatile guys that can go from
Durant to curry to klay Thompson not
have to worry about a big man lumbering
around up this is why Kevin love's had
problems against them over the years
Boston has that type of lineup but it
just would have been a step too soon to
ask Tatum brown Terry Rozier to play
that type of role if Kyrie had stayed in
Cleveland still don't think what Kyrie
was great a year-and-a he was brilliant
yes the reason it wasn't a sweep two
years ago no I don't know that they they
get demonstrable better maybe they win a
game maybe they go to six but he still
would've had the knee issue right yet
that didn't come up yeah I mean that one
thing during the season Boston and look
at I think of the exact minute total was
for Kyrie this year but it was in the
low 30s it wasn't like Boston was
burning him out the same way the Cavs
LeBron out that knee which nobody really
knew the severity of in a summertime
look Tyrese even said it he didn't know
if that those pins would have to come
out at all but it just started to
irritate caused that infection that
would have come eventually to what
wasn't this part of his game plan to get
out of Cleveland where he did say I'm
gonna have knee surgery and and people I
think doubted that at the Sun at the
time like do you really need knee
surgery did he need knee surgery while
he was still in Cleveland I think that
and Joe Vardhan over Cleveland calm was
the guy that first reported that I think
what he could have done is had some kind
of cleanup procedure I don't think it
would remember he had two procedures
with Boston right he had the first one
which was viewed as kind of a cleanup
procedure then they cut when they went
in there and they saw the aggravation
they realized what was going on with
those pins so I think what Kyrie was
talking about back in the summer the the
the reported threat was more about
having a cleanup procedure that might
have kept him out for the start of
training camp kind of you know kind of
needling the Cavs a little bit more
nobody you're never gonna convince me
Dan that somebody will voluntarily have
major surgeries to not play for a team I
don't I can't can't wrap my head around
that one we're talking to Chris Mannix
from Yahoo Sports
you made headlines couple of weeks ago
on the program where you talked about
the Lakers with the ingredients that
LeBron was adding with some of these
role players that this lineup could be
highly combustible so you bring in these
players and then I heard on one of these
shows where this was now an excuse an
excuse for LeBron if he brought in these
guys and they didn't do well well and I
went well he's how's he gonna fill the
roster you have to get guys who can play
these guys are experienced they may
bring some baggage but do you still feel
that way that what LeBron has and the
over unders 50 wins this year can a
combustible potentially combustible team
get 50 wins no I think they're in the 45
to 47 range and fighting for that eight
seed in the Western Conference I mean it
took 47 wins right to get to the
playoffs in the West this past year and
this is not a team even if you say you
love this roster and Rondo can work and
Lance can work and all these pieces will
eventually do what the Lakers are saying
they're gonna do
they're not gonna start fast like you
don't put this type of team together and
expect them to be even close to to 500 I
mean I think they'll think they'll
probably be 500 around Christmastime and
if you're gonna start like building it
up from there
you're in a tough conference I mean who
in that conference is taking this major
step back San Antonio I guess but you
can always count on the Spurs to to be
in the mix there
Minnesota's gonna be better I think
Denver is gonna be a tick better so it's
going to take that same number of wins I
just I think it's gonna take a Herculean
performs from LeBron in the second half
of the season to get this team into the
playoffs and I'm not convinced he's got
the the weapons around him to do it
can LeBron how does LeBron win another
MVP what is the likelihood that he wins
an MVP could he win MVP this season
maybe but what would that take I mean
look he'd have to play exactly as he did
last year offensively and better
defensively I mean he you know we saw it
no longer russell westbrook proved that
you don't have to be a 1 or a 2 seed to
win the MVP I mean that's not what the
Thunder were when Westbrook won his and
LeBron I think there are people out
there that are now re inclined to vote
for LeBron and once got to be LeBron
fatigued right it was like Roz Grant
thing with Jordan yeah same thing
now given the way LeBron played last
year and in the playoffs I mean that's
gonna be fresh in the minds still of
voters when they come to vote next June
I think if he plays exceptionally well
next year there'll be a lot of support
for him to win the NBA but don't you
think there was LeBron fatigue that you
could make a strong case that LeBron was
the most valuable player in the league
absolutely but I didn't vote for him
because he was horrible defensively
yeah but harden is horrible - yeah but
we've had this argument Harden was on a
team that was top ten in the NBA
defensively I don't give him all the
credit the world flats capela it's Steph
Curry's not a good defender
he's a serviceable but they're but he's
on a good defensive team yes but and I
think guys should get credit that
defense is not just mano-a-mano
individual there's a team connectivity
to defense and I thought Harden was
better in that sense and and look I'm
not exaggerating I mean I went on a West
Coast road trip with Cleveland towards
the the latter stage of the season I
just watched the broad defense
he wasn't doing it and I don't blame him
for that because of the the burden he
had to shoulder offensively but he would
just kind of stand there and sort of
look around and pointed guys to do stuff
on a couple of okay but wait a minute
how many times did somebody say man
Larry Bird's a good defender or you know
what I love about Kobe is his defense or
Metta they might have said it about Kobe
they didn't say it about Iverson I never
said anything about his defense I think
like we created this because it's LeBron
no I don't think we Critic as his LeBron
I think we're using it as a final metric
I mean James Harden was also a great
offensive player James Harden has done
some incredible things last couple years
and did them again this past season so
if you're looking at two guys that are
both great offensively you kind of go
down the list I mean wins there they
were number one Cavs are number four
whatever leave that aside then its
defense and hardens team and Harden was
part of a defensive team those top ten
and LeBron was what twenty nine was that
what the Cavs finished there do you
think Luke Walton is the coach of the
Lakers next year oh man that's tough I
I'm gonna say no I like Luke and I think
he's a I think he's a good coach I just
don't know how you succeed in that like
first of all he's again going to be
working for people that didn't hire him
which is first and foremost the toughest
thing to do as much as Magic Johnson
could say I love Luke I've followed his
career when you come in as an executive
every executive Masai Ujiri boot would
tell you this when you come in as an
executive you want to hire your own guy
and Luke Walton is not Magic Johnson's
guy he's not Rob Paul Anka's guys who
has got that working against him and
we've seen LeBron over the years dictate
terms when it comes to coaches I mean he
was influential in David Blatt getting
pushed out now do they hire who LeBron
tells them to hire that I think is a
more interesting question if it comes to
that but I think Luke's gonna have a
tough time damn I just don't know how
you go into that locker room for 82
games and manage all that and still win
and still win their respect and LeBron
and convinced guys that you don't didn't
work for before that you should be the
guy to stick around I think he's gonna
have a tough time keeping that job but
also Luke Walton brought in the system
from Golden State you can't can't
continue to play that sister now I mean
looked and I've
I've had so many conversations with
different people around the league who
look at the Lakers who were one of the
fastest tempo teams in the league last
year and LeBron James who for the last
four or five years has been one of the
slowest players in the league how do you
marry that this is why this I find this
this roster so kind of goofy I mean it
flies in the face of all the convention
about LeBron it's basically the Lakers
saying you know what Miami
Pat Riley Erik Spoelstra what you did we
got something better Cleveland you get
to the finals four straight years we're
gonna do something better they I mean it
sounds goofy but it feels like they're
trying to turn LeBron into Karl Malone
in the later stages of his career by
saying we'll make you a post player and
we'll let Rondo and Lance and other guys
have the ball in their hands whereas you
know LeBron is at his best when he has
the ball
that's why has it and so often all right
did we negotiate here pulley with the
haircut there's a lot of things going on
on this side of the glass Dan we're
trying to confirm whether the
quarter-inch guard a 3-inch guard a half
well let me give you look I came in
believing that i would do a four and
after listening to you talk about how
you said use a four for your haircut I
said you know what that's not real
that's not fair I had a four last time I
think the two is too short and I'm
looking at that two shirt so I'm willing
to use blue with every I'm willing to
split the difference and go to the three
by the way I've had so many people who
think I'm going to get my head basically
picked like I'm on social media and
people are thinking I'm gonna take a
straight edge to my head and be like
Aykroyd Konitz
yes fine there's a couple other things
from being thrown about the studio is an
option for Chris Mannix as he has gone
after the Lakers what about the Lakers
logo in the back of his head in lieu of
the haircut logos we're not doing logos
the back of that seems like you don't
know logo go ahead all right I can't
it's like when you tell someone like you
can get a fake tattoo and you make him
get the armband like you don't want you
don't want the armband in your arm you
don't want that logo in the back what
about it if it fits the NBA logo it's
Jerry well I can't I can't wake up every
day and what about like Yahoo like a big
Y would be great just have Y in the back
of your hair I have to get a couple
extra bucks that would explain a whole
lot though with you like why it has dual
purpose okay right so we do
sided so let's go on the other side and
yeah let me just say this though the
power of like I told seat in this
earlier this show I travel a lot
everywhere I go whether it's at a boxing
venue a basketball venue there's
somebody in the crowd yelling at me it's
all the time for the last few months
well that's nice yes bullying you know
the phrase shave your head keeps being
bandied about and you know the i-team is
all over this story this is the only
piece of audio we could find some of the
Mannix interview is missing from this
scene you seen you lost that one did you
see that this piece of audio that was
Chris that day I think we can put that
into context your head shave your head
clear your head hundreds of bad takes
over the last test five years you can
find them but not this all right let's
go to the other side here got a a little
miniature bathtub here little kiddies
pool bring in Ronnie from my hair place
one hi Ronnie
glad to have you a plug Thank You Ronnie
little plug for Mannix layer yeah all
right check the guard don't let them
know I know do we know Ronnie I have all
the guys here okay going 3 you have does
it say 3 on it it says it right on there
ok because I don't trust manage my trunk
you don't trust me trust you yeah Pauly
brought his in man if you're watching on
audience Channel 239 DirecTV the NBC
Sports Network
I've never had major surgery but I would
imagine this is what it feels no no it
does it I've had major surgery no it
doesn't know all right so that let's
inspect says three that looks Ruby says
3/8 3/8 of an inch all right that's what
we agreed to
you got it to there that's a
do one side will start one side ready
Chris I'm ready right get in the pool
yeah whatever you think is best there
yeah just start on the side here oh I
think it's gonna be I got an egg-shaped
head I think you're gonna be like a
Christian Bale camera one half start
yeah this Ronnie just do one half here
actually we need to go to break
we're right up against ekend okay let's
take a break and then we'll come back
because I want to ask Mannix about Kevin
Durant
ending up in Oklahoma City so we'll come
back after this
would it be great fan it's like Kyrie
already got traded to the Knicks right
now man had to go on TV yeah and like
should I grow a full beard out with the
shaved head like that's like a baseball
oh we got a big hockey hockey right for
the summer yeah
just love to let the beard go okay I
might try that yeah that'd be fun what
do you think though Napoleon think
shaves his own head oh yeah I use the
Clippers I do I should have cut it I
didn't cut it today yeah but he's going
for the Jason Statham look Chris Mannix
lost a bet at the Celtics going to the
NBA Finals and man of his word hanging
up his personal barber Ronnie is doing
the honors I feel like if you just left
this one strip right here down the
middle that would be pretty awesome well
the guys said that and I thought no it's
kind of mean-spirited Chris Mannix on
the other side of the glass I'll join
him in a moment from Yahoo Sports paying
off a bet he said the Celtics would go
to the finals back in November and lost
that bet so now he's paying up getting
his hair cut yes Paulie how would you
describe what Mannix looks like right
now kinda like a like a skateboarder
like someone like a Tony Hawk look hmm
hmm that's not fair to Tony Hawk way
back way
yeah but Mannix brought in his personal
barber Ronnie remember a flock of
seagulls land okay
he looks like a Houston cast member but
you made him keep the patch like he's
got a little bit in the front but we
decided that he was going to go with a
the razor three
it was a 3 3/8 inch 3 3/8 of an inch
I would love and they'll be awesome if
there was breaking news story
NBA wise and Mannix had to go on TV like
that that'd be good all right let me go
on the other side we'll finish up the
haircut if you're watching on audience
channel 239 DirecTV and the NBC Sports
Network
Mannix getting the finishing touches
here and I did want to ask him about
Kevin Durant he had something Maddox
said something last week about Kevin
Durant could end up in Oklahoma City all
right Ronnie go ahead finish up with
Chris Mannix here so explain this Kevin
Durant situation that okay it's Kevin
Durant with Golden State after next
season I'm gonna say no because look
three years in this is very difficult to
concentrate 80 million bucks three
championships blank slate at 30 years
old do whatever he wants now you mock
the Oklahoma City stuff but he's not
going LA because a guy with three
championships wants to compete with
LeBron four championships not you know
helping him anymore
and he's not going to Washington because
he never want to play in Washington ah
this is just a certain way here like
what a full metal night my power of
opinion is losing I'm actually I'm
starting to dislike Ricky Rubio Wow okay
so KD won't go back home to DC no didn't
even take a meeting with them a couple
years back and he's not gonna go to the
Lakers because he doesn't want to Braun
add to his legacy so if he's gonna leave
Golden State where do you look New York
he doesn't seem like he could handle New
York I'm just saying there's a lot of
salary cap gymnastics to go into like
figuring out a way back to Oklahoma City
but for a guy that's as sensitive as we
know he is yeah doesn't that solve all
the problems like he goes back to
Oklahoma City
nobody is he's criticized many more buts
like LeBron going back to Cleveland from
Miami it's it's I mean Katie's not from
there is that the same Allegiance of
course but I just think it's I look I
don't think I'm not saying he's going
there definitely but yeah I think he'll
be in the mix next summer wow that's a
hot cake I'll take it and we'll save
that one won't you see okay
that if Kevin Durant is not in Golden
State next year does anybody want to
take Mannix up on a bet
have you had a call of the year Kevin
Durant up but you're not gonna make me
take Oklahoma City right no no I'll give
you the I'll give you the field yeah
golden say the field I'll take the okay
does anybody one in on that with a
better with Mannix which might be
another haircut maybe an eyebrow that's
brutal
who does Mannix look like it's like
Christian Bale or he looks like the dude
from Trainspotting oh I'm gonna disagree
with your assessment there but I take
that good bad now he looks like a 60s
Celtic more than an 8 is okay
oh you're just getting a look at it now
it looks pretty good what do you think
looks younger yeah you're getting a lot
of he won the bet not lost you're
getting a lot of those comments right
now from women did the right thing
bringing his own guy in because I don't
think any of us could have done this no
no he did a great job
Quincy get the Manics after he's done I
mean I think it's called now Mannix is
mentoring and growing his beard for the
rest of the month the man were your
thoughts one piece
oh how gray is it gonna be I could be
pretty great no but not I'm not there
yet like I'm pretty good with with salt
and pepper II I think that you might you
might do well yeah we're trying I think
it'd be a good little imma try it I'm
gonna go if you move to Brooklyn
knocking OH
McLovin oh you're gonna put gel on that
Ronnie because we're gonna try to gel it
up alright let me go back on the other
side and finish my job here Chris Mannix
[Laughter]
that's good stuff
Mannix paying off the bet there he
wasn't sure what he was looking like
then all of a sudden he looked up in the
monitor and it was like oh I'm in
trouble here for more Dan Patrick show
to the audience channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]